قرارات محكمه روسيه احتجاز مراسل وول
ستريت جورنال الصحفي ايفان غريشكوفيتش
لمده شهرين على ذمه التحقيق بتهمه التجسس
وخلال محاكمته اكد مراسل ستريت انه غير
مدرب في التيامات التجسس المواجهه اليه
كما قال محاميه انه منع من دخول قاعه
المحكمه والاطلاع على الاتهامات
وكانت صحيفته
لمراسلها بالتجسس وطالبت بالافراج عنه
فورا ومن جهتها كدت روسيا ان تبادل مراسله
لن يحدث قبل محاكمته وصدور الحكم الخارجيه
الروسيه قالت ان اعتقال المراسل مرتبط
بالتجسس مشيره الى ان مكان يفعله ليس له
علاقه بالصحافه وقالت المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا الزخروبينا مراسله
وبالجرم المشهود اثناء تسريب معلومات عن
احدى المجمعات الصناعيه العسكريه الروسيه
من موسكو تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه كاتيا
مرحبا بك يبدو ان التطورات والتداعيات
تتصاعد في قضيه حتى الان ما هي اخر
التحديثات
مرحبا خالد بالفعل اليوم جلسه المحاكمه
التي عقدت اليوم كانت قد افضت الى اعتقال
المراسل مراسل الى مده شهرين وتم منع دخول
محاميه الخاص وتعيين محامي له من قبل
محامي تابع للحكومه الروسيه طبعا كانت قد
تحدثت الخارجيه الروسيه انه من المبكر
الان حديث عن امكانيه حدوث عمليه تبادل
لسجناء بين روسيا وبين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كانت ايضا قد تعلق الكرملين على
هذه الاعتقال وقال ان انه تم اعتقال
الصحفي متلبثا بعد طبعا توجهه الى مدينه
معلومات عن مجمع صناعي عسكري وهذا ما يدرج
تحت
اسرار الدوله في روسيا طبعا بالنسبه الى
الخارجيه الروسيه كانت ايضا قد علقت على
ان هناك العديد من الصحافيين الذين يعملون
تحت غطاء الصحافه ولكن يقومون بجمع
معلومات
لارسالها الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كما حدث اليوم والاتهامات التي وجهت الى
هذا الصحفي اليوم خالد